live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsay show we're here to help you
America win in your life specifically
your money and then we look at your work
and relationships as they tie into that
all-important issue of money we're here
to help phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five and with me the shower is my
colleague none other than the
incomparable uh delightful Rachel Cruz
wow yeah
I gave you two feels great I died
instead of college I thought well I'll
give you two there to get us started so
appreciate that good to see you it'll be
a good show it's going to be a lot of
fun we're here for you guys let's start
it off with Lauren who waits in Richmond
Virginia station I lived in Richmond for
a while when I worked for the governor
of Virginia I like to point out these
useless facts you always do with every
city I think it's the old man in me I
it's unfortunate there's a lot I'll try
not to do it today no
we'll do a city reference Lauren is up
Lauren how can we help
hey guys uh fun to know that you used to
live in Richmond
um yeah so my boyfriend and I are
currently planning out a potential
feature together so we've been going
through FPU and during that process
um and actually before that process he
shared that in a previous relationship
he co-signed on a student loan with his
girlfriend
um
so looking at that we're trying to
figure out do we pay that off is there
any way to like what do we do with that
because she never finished the degree
and so it's not likely that she's going
to pay it off anytime soon
um yeah wow I don't think I've ever
heard this one Rachel this is how long
ago was the relationship
um it ended probably two years ago and
it was three years long oh boy man
yikes well it's the girlfriends yes oh
gosh sorry yeah so sorry Lauren
ex-girlfriend is she is she behind on on
payments is she like where is she is she
she's paying them minimum payments but
it's just gonna
take forever right now it's in
forbearance so before she was paying the
minimum payment yes right now it's on
like hold and all that right but do you
know if she's planning on
at all being aggressive towards this
debt
no idea there's no contact did the oh
did the relationship end uh peacefully
you know
it wasn't tumultuous it just kind of
stopped so I just wonder is she gonna
try to stick it to him because he
co-signed for it yeah because the only
the only reason as a co-signer are you
kind of screwed is if they stop right
right payments and all of that but if
she continues to pay and it's just I
mean it would suck that she you know if
she has it for the next seven years he's
for seven years he'll be kind of
watching his back being like Oh gosh
you're not going to pay she gonna pay
but if you know but but you guys are
only or he sorry your boyfriend is only
on the hook
when
when or if something goes awry do you
know what I mean then yeah then he would
be how much is it
I'm 20 000 and what we're looking at is
okay so let's say we get married we've
been together all that a year from now
we go to buy a house and we've paid off
everything but that student loan is that
like negatively affect our credit score
like should we just pay it off to get
rid of it like what does all of it well
most of it is in her name yeah
um but again
I would want to know what she that's the
thing that sucks about co-signing is I'm
like your future is tied to this other
person right for until until it's until
it's paid off in student loans I mean
they're not bankruptible I mean like
this is a thing that's going to have to
happen so
um man I would hate for him to be the
one she could look if you guys had
contact with her to refinance sometimes
when you refinance you can get
you know
um get a co-signer off of the loan
student loans I'm are they federal or
private
Federal Federal okay I would look into
that Lauren and see and and it would be
worth a conversation
to reaching back out to her even though
it's probably very it's very awkward
um but to see if she would consider
refinancing to get his name off of it
because of his plans moving forward
um but if not I would hate for you guys
to be the ones to go and pay something
that's not yours and if she's not late
on them right like it's not gonna
penalize him
um necessarily but if she is late and
she doesn't pay on then that's the
that's the stupid tax that you pay as a
co-signer unfortunately and I and I also
hate to take us where we gotta go here
Lauren but you said we multiple times
do we need to pay this off and there is
no we unfortunately
okay so not yet well I'm very close to
like engagement marriage
okay very exciting but until then
nothing until then this is his problem
yes and I hate it for him but I I agree
with Rachel
um I would be reaching out with with the
olive French you know the metaphor to
say hey
so can I get my name off this can I
would you work with me on this
yeah you don't want to be with me yeah
okay with that you know I would try to
to negotiate that on good faith to say
hey
help me out do me a solid I tried to
help you out that was that was not so
smart that's right
um but again it would take her
she's got to play ball she's and and if
she doesn't it's like that's it I mean
but man we get this call with cars
houses you know this is a new trend by
the way I haven't asked you what you
think of this the new trend is and I'm
sure you know of this but a lot of
single people that may just be friends
they're not even romantically connected
well they're trying they're buying
houses together with both names trying
to get equity and all their own because
they can't afford to buy a house on
their own so they're going okay I'm
really good friends with my buddy Bob
yeah and so Bob and Larry are gonna buy
a house together and it's like that
can't end well no but this is a thing
that's happening names on the deed and
the mortgage all of it yeah no don't do
that I know because in the moment it
feels like a really Smart Financial
movement yeah what if a three or four go
together they all go well wait a second
I can put my down payment in you put
yours in and four of us become roommates
one house yep and then and not just
roommates but owning owners part
ownership you're right within it but
they think oh it's a smart roommate
playing we all get a little bit of
equity and it's gonna be and then and
then Bob goes off doing Bob's thing
why are all these people 80 years old I
think it's funnier because if I said
Eric it's not funny but if I say Bob
meets Luanne that's funny but if it's
Eric and Meredith something funny
that's why I go with the older names but
there really is something here don't do
that we're having fun with this but this
gets really contentious now what you can
do we've heard people do this is they go
and they buy
um you know a starter town home or condo
they get two roommates not on the
mortgage not ownership and they help pay
the the mortgage and all that you know
that's smart sure that's a that's a play
too you're offering them a discount with
when it comes to ownership yeah I mean
any level of sharing until unless you're
married and there's a legal binding
contract there uh other than that not
smart to uh not smart co-signed don't
put your name on people's dead don't go
in together think you're gonna get a
better deal with equity in the house and
all that because Bob and Luanne man they
are Trump they're gonna go do their
thing and poor Larry loses his pal
Annie may lose a lot of his money don't
do it Bob not worth it Larry
beep house you know play golf whatever
it is you do don't co-sign on a mortgage
and all that stuff it just never works
out there you go and Luanne is the bad
girl in all of them because she won
Bob's heart how did this all go so bad
because you didn't buy it the right way
for yourself so there it is all right
folks more crazy analogies funny names
and your calls coming up this is the
rantage
buying a home is one of the biggest
decisions of your life you need a
partner like Churchill Mortgage
Churchill is one of the highest rated
lenders in the country and their Ramsay
trusted because they do what's right for
you Churchill works with you to build a
mortgage the Ramsay way one that doesn't
bust your budget sets you up for
financial success and helps you get out
of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back America thrilled to have
you here on the Ramsey show as we take
your questions about your money and your
work and relationships we want to help
you break through and get where you want
to go financially and many times that
has a work component to it in fact uh
Rachel Cruz who's my uh co-host this
hour I'm I mean David said for decades
your greatest wealth building tool is in
fact your income yes and we believe that
he's right about that and and we live in
a world right now in an economy where if
you need to make more money to get
through the baby steps uh whatever baby
step you're on or you're just not really
happy where you are and you want to do
that thing it's never been better
unemployment is low uh the gig economy
is roaring uh and and I want people to
understand the gig economy you've never
heard that yeah like oh I get to teach
you a term so the gig economy is I have
a full-time job or
and so it's like so because it's so easy
now it's like gigabyte no sidekick Uber
Uber Eats or like a side hustle yeah
yeah they just call it the gig economy
everybody's got a phrase right go ahead
yeah it's kind of fun yeah I feel like
I'm gonna be in so as you know I'm
deeply passionate about helping people
make more money yeah and actually enjoy
doing it so they can get through these
baby steps that we talk about and so uh
I'm going out on the road Rachel no
backup singers we all travel together
for Building Wealth it's the Ken Coleman
it is the king Coleman show the Knights
of shine it's gonna be fun and so this
is for anybody Rachel who feels stuck it
could be a variety of reasons toxic
workplace uh I feel like I've hit my lid
there's not much growth opportunity
there where I am I want to launch a side
business I don't know what the idea is
or I know what it is I don't know how
and I'm gonna teach on a formula that'll
always give you a breakthrough when
you're dealing with some fear and doubt
and uncertainty and so I'll be speaking
on that formula and then doing the thing
that I love most is getting out in the
crowd because you're so good at thank
you you really are that you and deloney
yes and George and I do it when we're on
the road together you guys do it uh and
just that just the energy and the
engagement that's what's fun about these
kind of events and I'm glad you're
putting this in it because you know it's
one thing to sit in a seat and to watch
something and take it all in which is
what we usually do at Ramsay events
because we want to you know uh give you
instruction and inspiration all of it
but when you can add that element of
being with the p with people when you're
just down there I'm like there's a level
of energy to that type of event that is
so great and the content that comes out
of it it's real in the moment these real
life stories real life people talking
about what's going on and so yeah you're
a master at kind of pulling all of that
out and engaging in that way so these
events are gonna be so fun they're gonna
be a lot of fun and it could be a great
gift for somebody we have multiple
opportunities we have a VIP opportunity
to spend time before the event going
even deeper we're going to take
questions live from the crowd it's great
energy here are the day dates April 20
coming up in Kansas City Chicago
Illinois May 16 Atlanta Georgia May 18th
Dallas Texas May 23rd then get your
tickets right now at ramseysolutions.com
events ramseysolutions.com events I
would love to see you there high five
you hug you we're gonna have a big time
all right to the phones we go triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Sterling I wish my name was Sterling so
Annie's from Charleston he's got the net
selling right from Charleston it's
perfect Sterling from Charleston I'm a
little jealous of your name sir Sterling
how can we help
hey buddy I really appreciate that I'm
jealous of how smart you guys are right
well I'm about to expose that that is
unplaced jealousy here but we are going
to try to help you what's going on today
I appreciate it hey I have uh I've been
dealing I've been um listening and doing
the Dame Ramsey thing for the last five
years I'm I'm basically debt free now
because of y'all and I want to just
thank you very much for all that I
really truly do congratulations I'm a
huge fan and um but I did I was looking
at um at this solar thing I looked at
the um the last episode with Dave had a
question on there and I'm I'm just kind
of curious because the way I look at it
is a little bit different
um you know I like to say I'm debt free
but the way I look at it is my utility
bill is a debt and it's a lifetime debt
and if I go and put solar panels on my
home I'm going to eliminate that and
when my panels are paid off I'm not
going to have a utility bill or a solar
payment and that's when I actually own
my own electricity I am my now my own
electric electric company I'm not
depending on the local utility that has
ever changing increasing rate okay
sterling sterling you it's Sterling I'm
interrupting uh only because you have
proven to us all that you did a really
good job listening to their sales pitch
I feel like you've read the brochure
seven or eight times you nailed it yeah
you laid it out exactly child goes down
Sterling's gonna have electricity we're
all coming to Charleston to to have a
grill out at Sterling's house it's
burgers and dogs no Sterling listen all
right so let me ask you some questions I
have gas appliances though I'll still be
able to cook those before y'all but
Sterling I want to ask you some
questions how much is it going to cost
you
because you're going to have to finance
it after from there for the tax credits
okay it's gonna cost me roughly about
ten thousand dollars ten thousand
dollars total for your solar panels
after the tax credits after the 55 back
because we get a 26 a 25 state tax
credit and we also get a 30 Federal okay
but how is that applied because again
you're nailing the talking points how is
that applied what's your upfront cost
it's more than ten thousand
no oh okay so it's 20 000. we'll call it
twenty thousand I know I've been down
this road before Sterling I get it
twenty thousand twenty Grand yep all
right and so how long is that gonna take
you to pay off
well it all depends on the loan so let's
say it's set up on a 10-year loan I'm
gonna put it on 10 years sure
and the loan payment is going to be less
than it's about twelve dollars less than
what my utility bill payment is uh-huh a
month uh-huh and it never goes up it's a
fixed rate really good I know so you're
paying you're gonna you're gonna you're
gonna borrow money to save money down
the line on your utility bill and I
don't buy it I don't believe that your
utility bill goes to zero
so you've bought that bill of goods too
that's not absolutely true I don't think
that's true I would challenge you to
research that a little bit more and the
sales guys it doesn't go to zero let's
say it doesn't go to zero let's just say
it's very minimal let's say it goes from
200 a month to thirty dollars a month
all right they do do that I get it
brother so run the math on that all
right so we've saved how much money on
that example 170 right yeah 170 bucks a
month yeah per month times 12. I don't
have a calculator hold on let me get out
there we'll call it fit 1400 a year yeah
right so 1400 a year but you paid ten
thousand in loans plus interest here's
the deal if you want it so bad save up
the ten thousand and pay cash
okay that's my that's what I was gonna
ask you okay so don't borrow the money
bad thing okay don't borrow solar's not
bad I love the Sun
I need a little more sun look at me I'm
pasty I could use a little more vitamin
D Sterling but please come to Charleston
it's 85 today perfect oh very jealous
we're there yeah we're never going to
encourage anyone or suggest to anyone to
go into any kind of debt even it's for
the sun even for the sun period a
mortgage is the one type we won't yell
at you for but we have our formula that
we kind of run it through but other than
that we're not We're not gonna sit here
and say oh yeah you should go take out a
loan for 10 years for solar panels
because okay everything I have read and
again I'm not I'm not deep into this I'm
not a solar panel really I know you're
shocked and everyone's shocked even
though I drive a Tesla I'm not in solar
panels this is Mrs electric right now
but most of what I have read Sterling
when it comes to Renovations on homes
and and getting the value of your home
up solar panels it's a negative like it
it does not increase value for your home
I know you're not looking for the value
of your home you're looking for for your
utility bill
um so my thing would be because if you
want to say that the rates are going up
so much it's crazy what they've done in
the last even in the last 12 months I
mean I hear you 12 but Sterling you've
got to do right but you got to do more
research than the company brochure that
they've made to make sure no I have no
idea yeah so listen do your solar panels
I think it's great if you want to do
that but just pay cash don't take out a
loan go into debt acquire risk for the
fact to have these solar panels so
that's going to be true for anything uh
including the Sun what do you call those
things that we see on TV and cartoons
where a person's trying to get sun it's
like a reflector thing is that a
reflector that's not a solar panel
though that's a solar panel for your
face I know I kid you know listen you
got to be careful about all these things
there's a lot of nuances yeah you do
your homework
I don't know I like paying for my
electricity it's not dead it means I'm
cool and warm more
[Applause]
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
foreign
welcome back America you've joined the
conversation about your money your work
and your relationships here on the
Ramsey Show I'm Ken Coleman I'm joined
by my colleague Rachel Cruz we're here
for you this hour the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five back to the phones we
go Dallas Texas is where Don awaits Don
how can we help hi Ken hi Rachel good
afternoon to you good to talk to you
what's going on
well here's the deal um I'm 51 my wife's
about to turn 50. um I work for the
state I'm
a fraud investigator
um my wife
um to the Lord of great Heaven above she
got a better job and we're going to be
making a lot more money which you know
God grace is us so the issue is he
switched jobs now she has a fourteen
thousand dollars into her 401k and
um the issue is is that she wants to
move it and not leave it there because
it's kind of dead and kind of lose money
now the other issue is is that we want
to with this increasing and in about the
next two to three months we're going to
be totally debt free except for the
house okay so no debt except the
mortgage which we're gonna you know
still pay up a little early at the time
and all that but we want to start
investing more to to our age now so my
wife is an immigrant someone from the
church he's he's one of those guys you
need to do what I do for a living I
don't trust him he starts seeing how
iuls are the best thing in the world and
then annuities and all this stuff and
for the new Investments and he gave the
greatest Bill until I said here's the
thing my me and my wife trust the Dave
Ramsey people like you okay we trust we
trust you
um the thing is he thinks take this
money he'll be millionaires and all this
money from an iul or take that 14 000
from the 401K you can move it into
annuities and all this stuff so my thing
my two questions is she doesn't want to
roll over to her new job on the 401K
that 14 000 she wants to put into
something else maybe some kind of other
savings like mutual funds what have you
she's just she's not a fan of stocks you
know so my thing is we're going to
invest more one where should we move
that fourteen thousand secondly if we're
getting the best more should it be more
than the 401K and also should it be
mutual funds or something for our age
where we want to get that growth yes
okay great question so one thing she
needs to understand though mutual funds
are stocks they're 90 to 200 stocks put
into a fund so when you are invest
investing in your 401k 401K your Roth
IRA you know any types of those
Investments those are just kind of the
coverings under they use that money and
use that to invest within mutual funds
which we are a fan of we are not a fan
of single stocks so I understand her
risk if she's like oh I don't want to go
put all my money in the stocks in a
stock right because that feels uh that
feels scary but with a mutual fund
you're diversifying your risk you're
within 90 to 200 stocks so if I were her
I would roll over that 14 000 from her
last job you can even roll it over just
to a traditional IRA but if I were you
guys at your age Don I would pay off
your debt like you said you're going to
do in the first in the next two to three
months and then I would be maximizing
all of the retirement that I could and
so that is Roth IRAs that is 401ks uh if
you guys even want to look into like
your HSA health savings account there
can be a point even with that you stop
withdrawing for medical and you can use
that as a retirement vehicle all of that
so annuities the only reason that we
would suggest ever even considering it
is if everything is maxed out if your
house is paid off you are done with
everything a very a veritable immune
annuity is one that we would say you you
could do but we're just not a big fan of
it they don't keep up with inflation
there's tons of fees they're really
confusing they're hard to transfer it's
kind of a mess so no annuities is not
something that we are like big fans of
again there's fixed annuities very very
why can't I say that word it's tough
It's a tough word it's veritable it's
tough but all that to say that would be
the only reason Don that we would ever
even consider that so no this guy is in
the insurance world I mean I know his
spee I mean I know what he's what he's
pitching it sounds effective uh and so
no I would not be scared of what's going
on the market yes to not do great last
year but the market goes up and down all
the time and you guys are in your 50s
you still have another decade to write
all this out so if I were you guys I
would be flooding all of my retirement
up to 15 of my income into retirement
401ks Roth IRAs traditional IRA if she
rolls over from her job uh and then be
working to pay off the house that would
be my goal because that's going to be
the fastest way for you guys to build
wealth because again annuities I mean
there's
some of them don't even keep up with
inflation and so it's not it would not
be a route that I would take it's not a
route that I'm taking personally and Don
we want to encourage you if you don't
have a smartvester pro and you say hey I
trust the Ramsey people and then you
have a conversation with people that can
they can debate they think point for
point they got a very good sales case we
want you to get with a smart Master Pro
in your area go to ramseysolutions.com
interview two or three and as David said
many many times you want to make sure
that you understand why we say what we
say and you understand why you believe
that to be the best thing and I would
take your wife with you so that's the
best play they're gonna follow the
advice that Rachel just gave and they're
going to make sure you understand it so
you're in charge so we want you to do
that let's go to Boston Massachusetts
now John is there John how can we help
hey how's it going guys I appreciate you
taking my call you bet
um so my situation is kind of a personal
one
um I'm 26 right now a decent amount of
money saved up I don't have a house yet
my only debt is my car uh it will vote
um I'm working a sales rep uh role and
so with that I get a car allowance
um now I have enough money right now to
in order to pay off the car
um I'm wondering do I pay it off up
front and then continue to pocket the
car allowance or do I just keep throwing
the money from the car allowance towards
the car over the course of the next year
or so yeah will they still give you that
car allowance even if you don't have the
payments on it well they reimburse you
for other areas okay yes so in that case
I wouldn't 100 would just pay it off and
then you can just and pocket it because
at that point you have no risk you don't
owe anything on the car if you switch
jobs you're not stuck in this loan that
you could have had paid off and you're
still paying interest all of it so yeah
if I were you I would go ahead and just
pay everything off and then pocket yep
the car allowance if they'll do that
okay so basically like tomorrow would be
the best bet just hey get rid of the get
rid of the loan call it a day I would
how much do you have in savings
I have about 40 Grand in savings oh yeah
um and that's your only debt so why wait
till tomorrow I'm curious
well I guess yeah right now would
probably be a better bet huh I'm being
serious on that question because let me
tell you something
between this phone call
and the time it takes for you to get
with your bank and pay it off today you
might run into somebody who's got a
different opinion you might start to
doubt it and think about well I sure
would like to keep that eleven thousand
you know and so we can all do this I
don't care if it's a relationship
decision that we know we need to make
um a financial decision a professional
decision a physical decision you know
what I probably should throw out all of
the chips and salsa in my house if I
want to lose 20 pounds and then you go
if I don't do it right then and there
well I can tell you I'm eating chips and
salsa later that night I mean it's this
idea of if you've decided act in this
moment like hang up the phone
and start the process right now and I
just I I I'm this is a human condition
we all do this once you decide do it
don't wait it makes sense
it does yes and I guess the only thing
kind of holding me back from it and the
reason why I wanted to ask the question
in the first place was that uh we were
trying to save up for a house so I
didn't know if it would make more sense
to keep more money for a down payment or
whatnot uh rather than pay off the car
since I have that car allowance coming
in yeah no I hear you no yeah I would
yep I would still I would be debt free
and then the right the remaining
um money that you have you know that 35
000 I would have an emergency fund so I
wouldn't even put that towards your down
payment I would look to see okay what's
three to six months of expenses take
some of that cash put it aside and then
from there start building up your
emergency or your down payments for baby
step 3B and the great thing is John
you're having this car allowance come in
that's like free money to put toward the
down payment yes and not a car loan
nothing going out so you can just you
know save that up so that's what I would
do John in that order yeah because
here's what happens pay it off now you
have no debt and ooh we get a nice jump
start in the form of a car allowance 2
building up that the down payment I got
to tell you you're going to be so happy
you did this don't wait hang up go go
now do it do it right now so exciting
you know it would be fun to see if we
could zoom in and watch him do it you
know see it live see it live you know
just some watch somebody just pay their
car off because so few people do that
but anyway good stuff thank you for the
call John uh we appreciate you very much
all right we'll be right back don't move
more Ramsey show coming up
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague
Rachel Cruz and if you're new to the
program whether it's on YouTube or your
favorite podcast platform or radio
SiriusXM however you're engaging with
the program and you hear this jargon you
hear baby steps you're kind of going
what's this whole thing about where do I
fit in this deal we've got a wonderful
tool for you called get started and
allow you to just kind of see where you
are financially and how we can get you
plugged in and get the resources that
you need it's the get started button on
our website ramseysolutions.com
ramsaysolutions.com click on get started
and we'll get you off and running let's
go to Atlanta Georgia now where Hunter
is Hunter how can we help
how's it going guys uh we're having a
blast what's up
so I'm 20 years old I make about 72 000
a year
um I'm really looking to get into the
house either here soon or I'm thinking
maybe I should wait next year for the
housing market to kind of come down a
little bit I'm just looking to DL stocks
on that
um wow well that's
um
I mean your young young guy and look how
much you have saved to buy a home
I've got about six thousand I know I
haven't really started the saving
process okay okay just after paying off
all my credit cards that's kind of what
I've been a minute before in within the
past two months yeah that's a great I
think
um Hunter are you in school at all or
are you you're just working full time
just working full time
yeah good for you good for you
um here's what I would eye with Hunter I
feel like we answer these questions
sometimes if I were to wake up in your
shoes at 20 years old I'm assuming you
have no other debt you said you paid off
your credit card so no other debt
just a short note yep just a way just a
truck note okay how much is that
it's about 500 a month well total what's
the loan thirty thousand whoa whoa
that's a nice what kind of truck truck
Hunter just an F-150 just an F-150 that
thing would run over my car like I was a
Matchbox car those things are gigantic
uh and so you've got a a truck note and
do you have any savings at all just the
six thousand
just the six okay okay so
um
here's what I would do Hunter and what I
would Kelly Blue Book the truck
and just see that's my favorite thing to
do what year is it
2015. 2015 F-150 all right how many
miles
when did you buy it
uh two months ago okay recent purchase
um
so we always say if you can't pay off
your car and 12 to 18 months you have
too much car so the fact that you makes
you make 70 a year is that what I heard
72 yes 72 okay
um so you have no expense you're living
with your mom
um not a lot of expenses so you could
pay this off in a year so if you loved
the truck and wanted to keep it
I my next step would aggressively be
paying off this truck I would work extra
I would do it as I would pay this off as
fast as possible I would throw five
grand of your six grand at it and get it
out because we have found Hunter the
fastest way to build wealth from point A
to point B and wealth that you that you
keep not just like this lottery winner
type mentality is becoming debt free
having Savings in the bank that you can
get to what you when you need investing
and real estate so all of these are Big
components of building a really solid
Financial picture so for you that first
hurdle is getting debt free and so this
will be your truck so you could either
sell it did anything come up Ken I'm I'm
narrowing it down letting you do the
advice here so I would I would either to
get to get you on this plan faster
would be to sell the truck and start
saving up a fully funded emergency fund
but if you wanted to keep the truck then
it would take you you know nine months
12 months longer in this process to pay
it off then I would want you to get a
big emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses and then start
looking to buy a home and for your first
home
um you know I would save anywhere from
five percent up to 20 20 is great I know
that's a lot in the market today but you
avoid PMI you avoid there's a lot of
great things of having that 20
um but for first-time home buyers we
would say five percent so so there's a
couple of things I would do Hunter
before I go and purchase a home so I
want to give you the numbers to plug in
so what is it at an outstanding State
all right you it's worth 17 364 dollars
clean 16-8 average 15.9 where did you
get a 30 000 if you bought this two
months ago it looks like you paid double
for it
they were hard to find I was trying to
get I had a brand new F-150 and I was
paying about a thousand a month for it
so I decided to stop being stupid and I
cut it in half that's still not the
smartest no yeah so you overpaid
um and this is what this is uh according
to Edmonds so I mean you can do your
homework on this but that's what you're
looking at but if you were to do that
then how we walk people through that
Rachel what do we do yeah so what you
would do hunter in this case is you
would sell it for what you could man I
would go back to the guy and be like
25. who'd you buy it from you don't have
to say their name we're not trying was
it was it a dealer or was it a
individual it's a dealership it was a
dealership they're not they're not gonna
do that man Hunter oh shoot I hate that
for you did you did you look to see the
value of of F-150s around at that at
that year or you just were doing quick
making quick decisions making quick
decisions trying to get out of the bad
decision all right so you know what
Hunter this is great you're 20 years old
you made a mistake you can get out of it
do you feel that you feel that you're
like oh crap I could gotten this for 17
000 but I paid 30 for it that wasn't
smart so you're learning this now which
is great learn it now versus learning it
over and over and over again when you're
40 years old so so I would I if I were
you I would take the hit and just say
man I'm gonna go take out a small loan
and I would you know take out a you know
twenty twenty one thousand dollar loan
which is going to cover your under
because you're underwater in it so it's
going to cover the difference and leave
you a couple of thousand bucks
um no I wouldn't you have money saved
Hunter no no I'm so sorry what condition
is it in what would you say outstanding
outstanding I would say all right so
let's say you could get 17 for it all
right you've got six in the bank all
right so if you get 17 for it you're
still gonna have to get the smaller loan
like Rachel's talking about that covers
the difference if you owe 30. so you got
about 13 if you don't put it into it if
you put six into it now you're down to
Seven Grand but the challenge I know
that's why I'm walking through it so
you've got to have a car so I take the
six and I'd get myself a decent SUV
that's going to get me from point A to
point B yeah okay now I'm going to pay
off the seven as fast as I possibly can
that's right that's right that's what I
would do and then Hunter you build back
up so then you get yourself a fifteen
thousand dollar truck after you save up
some money you sell the other one and
you kind of Step your way into it you
get a decent car and now we start saving
for a home that's the process because
here's if you don't do that I want you
to understand why Rachel's recommending
this the this truck is devaluing every
time you drive it and unless you're
going to go all in and pay the 30 000
off like really soon it just doesn't
make sense to do that you're so
underwater with this thing yes does that
make sense to you
yes sir so let's take the hit so take
the third so yep take the Thirteen
thousand dollar loan versus the 30.
that's right you're switching you're
swapping those two
and then take I would take five of the
six have your baby emergency fund of a
thousand dollars go get a five thousand
dollar there you go car
Civic issue whatever it is and it's not
gonna be a pretty car Hunter you're used
to driving a brand new truck now you're
used to driving a nice thirty thousand
dollar truck it's not gonna feel like
that but that's okay that's okay because
again your goal here is to get from
point A to point B of Building Wealth
and the fastest way to do that is for
you to use your income a great income
Hunter you're making 72 000 at 20 years
old it's incredible I found him a car ah
okay I went on a website and uh I typed
in uh used cars under 5 000 in the
Atlanta area which I see a 2002 Toyota
Sequoia perfect 225 000 miles but those
things will run for five hundred
thousand and you only need it for like
79.95 you only need it for like seven
months because you're going to be saving
it on the side too Hunter and you're
gonna sell the Sequoia for five thousand
dollars again because it's probably not
gonna go down in value and then you're
gonna match it with another five
thousand that you save from your income
and then you're gonna step up to a ten
thousand dollar car and you're gonna
slowly keep doing that until you're to
the point that you're like yeah I have
some cash to spend so it is possible
it's possible to do this and that's what
we would do Hunter does that make sense
thanks for calling in and that's the
first vehicle I found I mean you want
the gas savings how about a uh Camry for
3 800 there you go those things will run
do this all day but your pride is Gonna
Hurt Hunter I know don't let your pride
get in the way yeah that's 20. the
camera that camera is not pretty but
it's fine you're only gonna have it for
six months there it is so it can be done
Rachel Cruz fun hour thanks for hanging
out always fun to be with you I want to
thank James Childs and our fearless crew
behind the glass for keeping us on the
air and we want to thank you America
this is your show this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
hey it's Ken if you love the show and
want a deeper dive on your money Journey
we have a Weekly Newsletter that gives
you trending and helpful articles and
tips on following the Ramsey win go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsey Show it's where we help you win
in your life specifically your money and
we look at it from a relational and a
professional work standpoint as well I'm
Ken Coleman joined by my colleague
Rachel Cruz the phone number if you want
to if you want to jump in on the
conversation is triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
let's go to Idaho Falls Idaho Merrill is
there Merrill how can we help
hi Ken and Rachel thanks for your time I
appreciate it you bet well
um kind of had a curveball thrown thrown
at me
um I turned 61 next month and I'm being
downsized out of a 25-year career oh I'm
sorry what uh what's the industry
medical sales okay hmm
um I try to live life without any regret
but I got to be honest I've regretted
not finding you guys about a decade
earlier I'm new to you guys and um I you
know just appreciate what you do but
here's my situation life has changed
obviously
um
I've not been the best with money
throughout my life
uh we're looking at you know a massive
change as we just spoke
my financial situation is this is we're
debt free other than the house which is
a good thing yeah
um how much do you own the house
we owe 278. what's it worth
606 between 600 and 650. okay
um my I've got a 401k
um last I checked was at about 5 40.
um but 60 of that is in a 401h
and me not being the numbers guy I don't
think we can touch that I think that's
set aside for
for Health Care going on which we need
because my wife has issues has her
entire life
so my initial question is this
um
our mortgage is 1600 a month
would it be smart and could I do it
without getting destroyed by taxes to
pay off the home
out of the 401K once
once this is done it would relieve some
stress it would cut into a substantially
you know but then
the second part of the scenario is
you know work is is on the horizon for
sure for longer than I'd anticipated and
uh what do I do next so I want to focus
on that tomorrow I want to focus on that
part first and because real quickly and
then I want to walk through some money
options here Rachel
um you've been in sales for a long time
and just because you've been in medical
sales for 25 years I believe you said
doesn't mean that you can't sell
something else I mean I think you know
this but it's kind of a mindset thing to
go wait a second just because I've got a
lot of experience in one industry
doesn't mean that I can't transfer the
skill plus the experience to another
industry true or false
[Music]
Peru
um I think what I've found though even
is getting on some of the sites I don't
even know what to search out you know I
don't even know you know just so new to
the process you know I'll help you with
it I'll help you with it here's where I
want you to start I want you to start do
you want to stay in sales presumably you
enjoy sales and I think it's pretty
obvious you're good at sales is that
true
well that can to be honest yes I love
cells as long as it's a specific type
I think you know what I'm talking about
um
Corporate America at least in my
industry in the last 10 years has gotten
pretty intense and being an older guy I
want to help people I would love to have
a customer come to me and help them do
the right things yes
um now we're going somewhere it is now
we're going so here's what this is tying
right into the exercise I was going to
give you you don't have to answer it on
the show I don't want to put you on the
spot and I want to get to these money
options but I want you to think about
the services or the products
you think in your general area of Idaho
Falls the small businesses start there
because you don't like big corporators
so let's look at small business Now in
America that's I think that's a
classification of about 500 employees or
less so what are the products or
services in your area that you have a
connection to you like them uh you use
them uh or you you know some companies
that you hear good things about and you
know that when you sell something you're
selling a product or service that you
believe in let's start the research
there let's not just go on some job site
and look for sales positions let's do
some homework let's talk to people
you're 61. you know a lot of people and
I'm going to give you my book to get you
jump started it's called the proximity
principle okay I'm going to give that to
you and I want you to read it and
leverage those relationships if you want
to you could jump further on into the
book and read about the web of
connections you know way more people
than you realize
you put the word out about what's going
on the type of sales role you're looking
for the type of culture you want to be
in and Meryl I'm I've got news for you
in this economy right now you're going
to get hired quickly but you got to be
intentional and you got to put the word
out all right now I want to get to the I
want to get to the money stuff here
because Meryl said something Rachel that
I I wanted you to weigh in on instead of
using that 401K money to pay off the
house if it's just you and your wife and
I don't know that it is Meryl but if
it's just you and your wife why not sell
the house and maybe downsize a little
bit and you still take away the debt but
you still have the 540 000 I believe you
said in the 401K is that an option and
Rachel is that a good idea yeah what
what how attached are you guys to this
house
what I have a question we've been in at
20 years and we still have two older
children that are not quite form and
Nest yet but are very close how old are
they
um 19 and 20. okay okay yeah so and you
guys are saying you're 61. is that what
you said
yes ma'am yeah so you're past the 59 and
a half age Mark to be pulling from
retirement so my my thing could you pull
yep could you pull 278 out of retirement
that would leave you guys besides the
401h that you have it would leave you
around 200 000 left in that 401k if you
just did that today
um so my question would be to run the
numbers for you guys to say okay
does your wife have any retirement
either just does she have anything
no she's um she's been disabled like
okay okay um so I'm a stay-at-home
mother and did an awesome job okay
wonderful nope that's great that I
applaud that for sure
um so what I would look at to say okay
with this 200 000 in retirement with a
new job that I'm gonna take and flood as
much of that money back into the
retirements what can we live off of what
is our lifestyle and so that's going to
be you guys running some numbers on what
your budget looks like what your
lifestyle looks like but honestly Mira I
I probably would not do that no
um I'd sell the house if it was me
because the 19 and 20 year old need to
fly the coop at some point and if we got
a downside 400 that'd be 400 000 in
equity from the house and you pay cash
for something small cash for something
for 400 000 then then there's no
Mortgage in the picture you guys have
your 500 you know half a million dollars
in your 401k left and work for five or
six more years they're good yeah so it's
basically like yes so that I mean
honestly Meryl that's probably what I
would do but I know that's so easier
said than that I always have something
with the house because I understand but
I would not pull
278 out of your 401k because you guys
are gonna have to eat and so you want to
be able to run some of those numbers and
I would sit down with a smart investor
Pro for them to look at your entire
Financial picture for you guys since
you're going to be the sole provider and
have been and just to kind of run some
of those numbers to say okay what how
much do I have to make in a job but you
don't want to work forever either you
want to retire
um so look at looking at those options
it's gonna be important and you did
great Merrell people are in a lot worse
situation than you guys are so you said
I was bad with money but you guys are
doing great doing great thank you for
the call don't move more Ramsey show
coming up
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
Shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed Perfect Fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
thank you
welcome back America thank you for
joining us here on the Ramsey show the
phone number to jump in is triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's go to Syracuse New York Julie
is there Julie how can we help
hi Mr Ken hi Miss Rachel thank you for
taking my call you bet
I am 60 new I have I'm single I have one
son on debt free yeah and I need and
want to retire I put 18 in my 401k
I have a nine-year-old car with a
hundred and ten thousand miles
I have my bills I can get by on
approximately 3 200 monthly expenses
little tight but I can do it
but I will have to pay for my health
insurance on top of that I want to do
some Renovations kitchen cabinets and
flooring and with cash flow this my
question is
should I drop my 401 to 15 and use the
extra cash for the runners or honestly
can I is it even safe for me to retire
my goal is not to spend my 401 I have
one son and I want to leave the base of
that to him maybe just pull off some
interest if I needed I have checked into
Social Security I will get approximately
two thousand a month for that and I have
checked into
my pension and I'll get approximately 2
000 for that my 401 is
544 dollars in 22 cents and of course
that's really
continuing to lose
well it's not losing unless you were to
pull it out it's just riding the roller
coaster right now in the stock market
obviously hit hard last year but we were
returning it's doing better they're
expecting it to to end up positively
this year so it may take a couple years
to get back to how much is in your
pension Julie
if there is no lump sum pain and I've
checked into that you can't take you
there's not an option for lump sum for
you no
so the pension
um and Social Security is going to get
you four thousand a month so that's uh
and and do you owe anything on the home
I own my home okay so you're completely
debt free
completely so your question is is hard
paid off the base of my home now what he
doesn't know is I have the money in the
bank page for him but so how much is it
how much is in the bank besides
retirement what else do you have to your
name
okay I just put 42 000 into a CD because
it was in my money market and it wasn't
making anything and I'm getting four
percent on that and I only did it for
six months because the Market's so
volatile that if the interest rates went
up I wanted to be able to change it
other than that I have
at least 26 000 in there
forty two thousand or twenty six
thousand I have 42 000 that I just moved
from my money market into a CD into a CD
for six months and I have 26 000 in the
bank on top of that oh on top of that
I'm sorry okay perfect okay
um and Jill your question is should you
take you've been funding 18
should you take it down two percent and
you're asking if you should take it down
to 15 and you're 62 is that correct yes
and what's your plan for retirement do
you have a date do you look out there
and say in October of this year I really
wanted to go and my son wanted me to go
in January but with the market it's just
it it's not feasible but it's becoming
harder and harder after 40 years and
this is yep I hear you I hear you well
the the positive thing Julie if your
numbers are all correct
um I mean you're gonna have four
thousand dollars a month from the
pension and social security
um so that's going to take care of all
of your expenses you don't have any debt
you have no payments so anything extra
that you would take for renovations or
do things you want to do will be
interest off that 401k and that will
just continue to grow oh I know that it
looks bleak right now but but the market
is returning and over time I mean you're
62. so by the time you're 82 that's
going to continue to grow and you can
even take how much of the renovations
because even taking some of the money
that you have in your CD you could take
a few thousand dollars for that and get
some new cabinets too
how much will that cost the renovation
I'm hoping to keep it at 30. okay
flooring throughout the house and then
there's some cabinets for the kitchen
but on that four thousand that I get a
month that's before taxes plus if I quit
now I don't have my health insurance
that's already taken out of my paycheck
so I'm going to have that on top of it
makes me very nervous yes well so let's
look at this what is it let's say that
you could walk away today nothing to be
nervous about let's say you could walk
away today what does retirement look
like for you what do you think your day
looks like and I'm serious like through
the week are you are there hobbies are
you doing are you sitting around
watching the prices right I mean what
does it look like for you
um just lunch and
I'm the girls and maybe go visit at my
son I love it yeah here's one thing I
would recommend
um I've been studying this because I
think retirement's overrated and what I
mean by retirement is this idea that I
work for a long time let's call it 40
years and all of a sudden I just stop
one day and now I'm just recreational
and there's a lot of data out there
about how that really uh begins a
physical a cognitive emotional Decline
and so I'm going to challenge you to say
that part of the fix for this could be
you could walk away from your current
job and retire but you could pick up a
part-time job that's fun and you know in
a great environment you're doing
something you enjoy no stress and that's
how you fund projects like the
renovation I just don't like the idea of
pulling a large sum of money to do a
renovation to a home at this stage in
your life now I'm talking to you as
though I would be talking to my mom and
I'd say this is what I I wouldn't do it
that way I would find a way to save up
the money and cash flow it I'd work a
little bit longer on the health care
issue I would take care of those things
and not be in a hurry for traditional
retirement I just think I'd take a
little bit more time be a little bit
more patient maybe a little bit more
aggressive or if I'm gonna retire I'm
gonna find a way to still make some
money
okay Julie how much will the health care
be have you run any numbers on that what
it'll be for you I have looked in for a
moderate and that means if anything were
to happen you've got at least 10 000 out
of pocket which really terrifies me it's
going to be about four to five hundred a
month four to five hundred a month okay
so yeah I mean if yeah if I were you
with the renovation stuff I would go
slow I mean they're not gonna be pulling
any money out
um no I would not pull out any money
from the 401 for renovations that's just
not enough yeah and I would and you have
yeah and you have a good cushion when
you have 88 000 liquid
um and so that that's a that's a great
emergency fund probably way more than
what you need uh because we even talk
about you know it's three to six months
of expenses and that's that uh I would
sit down with a smart investor Pro and I
would invest a good chunk of that make
that start working for you now because
now's a good time to buy into this
Market it's going to go up the
historical Trends just lay this out this
is not some crystal ball Ken's got a
prediction uh I I would sit with one of
our smart vest approach Julie and I'd
take some of that cash
um and and I would invest that and and
let that grow okay keep maybe 20 in in a
you know you have it in a CD yeah or a
high yield savings and all that they're
getting great rates of return like what
you're saying which is awesome but keep
maybe 20 in that that you don't touch
it's just there for God forbid you just
need it one day don't you know just
don't even think about that and then
everything else to just say what what
can I put my money in that's gonna make
a large because the market right now
you'll get a better return still
with the CD so turn off the news to
Julie because I think sometimes we can
get in our heads about how scary
everything is and it feels like the
world is crashing down but sitting with
down with somebody and running these
numbers out extensively of your
lifestyle what you need to pay and get
some of these facts down I think is
really going to help you make that
decision but your lifestyle is is low so
I feel like you're at a point that
retirement's not too far off that it
really is doable for you with these
numbers so I would not be as fearful uh
as what you're feeling but get some more
numbers with your health care and all
that and look to see Dad sit down with
the smartvestor pro and see how much can
I how much interest can I just live off
of off these Investments by investing
even more into it yeah Julie thank you
so much for the call you're going to
figure this out facts are good get as
many facts as possible I'd love you to
sit with one of our smart master Pros in
your area as well ramseysolutions.com
for that don't move more Ramsey show
coming up
[Music]
foreign
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see if chm could be right for your
family learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
foreign
welcome back America thrilled to have
you here listening and watching the
Ramsey Show I'm Ken Coleman I'm joined
by my colleague Rachel Cruz this hour
we're here for you the phone number to
jump in for your money questions your
work questions today triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
I'll tell you what I think would be fun
I'd love somebody who's really
struggling
um in your occupation because you're in
a really nasty or maybe toxic
environment or you got a a real doofus
of a boss or maybe some gossipy
co-workers I'd like Rachel away in on
some of that because you're so nice and
I I could give them some tactical stuff
on on work but I I would like maybe a a
pretty juicy situation for you to waste
on terrible boss situation or maybe
they're just feeling like I feel stuck
because I I've got to pay off debt and
we can get you out but if you're dealing
with a tough situation let's take one of
those calls I'd like to bring Rachel
into that I think she'd give some really
really interesting advice I really do
well thank you Ken I think I'd like to
see a little sad let's see a little sass
coming up the SAS only comes when it's
natural We're Not Gonna oh I know we're
not gonna I think you're a fighter for
people you hear a negative situation you
get a little fired up so I'm hoping for
that we'll see Triple eight eight two
five five two two five all right
Charlotte North Carolina is where we go
Phil is there Phil how can we help
thank you so much for taking my call I'm
sorry I don't have a
have a situation but I do
I do have a question just bottom line up
front great no problem what's going on
trying to trying to figure out uh if I
should stay in the military or not oh
I'm in nine years now and I just feel
like I'm professionally stagnating
um what branch but
I'd rather not say just keep it kind of
yes I appreciate that well thank you for
uh thank you for serving our country
you're a great American Phil and so
we're grateful for that so why do you
feel like you're languishing what's
going on
uh so it's it's kind of a long story
I'll try and keep it short I have two
approaches I have a logical approach and
an emotional approach The Logical
approach says I should stay in this
practically recession-proof job to
provide Securities benefits a house for
my for my wife and my family
um and at the end of 11 at the end of 11
more years we get we get a pension and
now my wife doesn't have to work she
could want to work but she doesn't have
to
um what now that makes that it makes
logical sense but it comes at a cost of
mental exhaustion exactly professionally
stagnating and when I get out I would be
behind my peers in the corporate realm
as far as what they're doing in
Corporate America that's one side the
emotional side is I know I can get out
and I know I can make six figures yes
sir I've had multiple I've had multiple
offers but it's not as stable and I'm
essentially walking away from what could
potentially be probably a multi-million
dollar pension and take in taking away
that security from uh from something
that's more dependable
yeah so I think you've created it and
then and then there's the logic and then
there's a motion I'm wondering if there
is a spiritual or other answer that can
sort of provide some guidance there is
in that realm I'm so glad you took us
there I probably would not have gone
there but since you took us there I'll
I'll step right in there I do believe
there's a spiritual answer and I think
it corrects the false narrative that
you've created I think you've created a
false choice
but I will tell you that the spiritual
answer first is that
you were created to work
the the Bible says you are uniquely and
wonderfully made and part of that isn't
just the skill the other part of that is
what you desire to do there are just
certain things have you ever met
somebody that's just doing a job and
they just they've got to bounce in their
step and they love it and you talk to
them about it you go I just love this
that's unique to them because somebody
else could do that job and be miserable
within 30 minutes and so to acknowledge
your Creator and your unique creation
and how you're wired that's the
spiritual answer I will also go one step
further there's a soul craving
to make a mark to make a difference
Rachel's Soul craving is different than
mine yours is different than ours we all
have this craving to make our unique
contribution and and it just once we
start getting a sense that what we're
doing isn't it and I think that's where
you stand right now you may not know
what it is you might but what you feel
right now is a meaninglessness to what
you're doing even though that what
you're doing is not meaningless it's a
it's a missing Soul connection and so
that's the spiritual answer now real
quick on this false narrative
this idea that if I go make six figures
in the corporate world I'm so glad you
acknowledge that you can because you can
but that I go do that
and yet it's not stable because
Corporate America We Lay people off of
recessions happen I I get it that you
got the fixed income and the pension
with the military but at what cost
of your soul dying
and you having to fight that battle to
not let that affect your marriage to not
let it affect your mental health your
physical health your emotional healthy
the data says that that people that are
unhappy at work I just shared this on my
show Rachel this week people that are
unhappy at work live on average 10 years
less than people are happy this is
science here this isn't my opinion some
uh Phil I I think that you got to go
make more money invest that money wisely
your wife won't have to work and I think
you can make more over time using our
investment principles
and you can get another job if you get
laid off
how old are you Phil
31. oh my gosh you can out earn that
that military pension by just going to
work in in the real world
so I don't think you have to worry about
it so what if you get laid off
I was laid off at 32.
I made more money the year after I got
laid off than the two years prior
so this idea that I'll have to stay in
the military
that's stable and if I go to the private
sector even though I can make more money
it's super risky I don't think you're
risking anything does that make sense
it it does I wouldn't say and maybe I
misspoke I don't want to say super risky
just relative to the relative to the
other decision 100 then it would be
riskier I acknowledge them but that's a
calculated risk do you see the
difference right um I'm I'm curious I've
read I've read the book um I'm curious
just on your all's opinion I understand
your views on pensions and how they're
less in control of they're more in
control of the companies than of the
individuals uh does that same rule apply
to the to the like government like
government pensions well you tell me I I
haven't served in the military do you
have any control over your investment
strategy within that pension fund
yes okay how much
well with the tsp like we can do
whatever we want with it exactly uh but
with the with the pension at the end of
it you you it gains around right and I I
don't know this I just know what I read
on charts but it gains over time with
cost of living sure uh but let's do the
flip side though let's flip this though
how much money are you making right now
um
based on what the website says including
everything 87 000. no I'm asking you
your salary that's what you make
yes okay so that threw me off how you
answer that okay you make 87 000. what
if you're making a hundred and eighty
seven thousand and you're investing
wisely and you have no debt how much
more ground are you going to make have
you run those numbers I mean I think you
really have to because you're you're
aware of what you could make well what
if you lived financially frugally and
you walk the baby steps out and you're
investing that money how much further
you're going to behead uh after all
those years
sure well Phil I mean what I would say
to you is you're 31.
the point that Ken is making is that you
can go may even if it's not 137 maybe
it's 120 right you but you're making
great money out in the private sector
you start investing you retire
a multi-millionaire because you would do
that if you start investing 15 of your
income into retirement so regardless of
whether it's huge Millions medium
Millions the quality of life between now
and retirement you can't put a price on
that and I would rather enjoy my life
and retire with I'm just throwing out
numbers two million dollars then 3.2
million and have actually enjoyed what
I'm doing so that's where you can't put
a cost on it Phil so I think that you
have a lot to offer and I think that yes
yes relatively there's risk but honestly
out there I'm like there's so much to be
had and so much opportunity that you're
going to continue to make more than what
you're going to make in the first year
into working so I think I think that
you're you're spot on yeah and don't
live a life that you're correct you got
this
[Music]
I
think
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague
Rachel Cruz we're here for you this
shower taking your money questions and
if uh if you got some job related junk
that affects the money meaning you want
to get out but you're worried about the
money
I'll take those questions today with
Rachel as well the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight eight two five five
two two five well uh it is that time of
year where I spit nails and that's when
I think about taxes uh if you got
questions about taxes we get it taxes
are confusing it's scary and we want to
unpack a question Rachel from one of our
listeners regarding taxes the question
is I'm really nervous about trying to do
our taxes ourselves believe me I get it
uh but it's almost 300 to get them done
with a tax Pro what should I do well
if your tax situation is simple you can
definitely try using a tax software like
Ramsey smart tax ours is the best and
it's going to guide you through the
online filing process step by step and
you don't pay until you file so you've
got a chance to figure out did I get it
right I feel good about this uh before
you submit now the federal classic
version of Ramsay smart tax comes with
built-in support that helps so you do it
all yourself but if you're a little bit
unsure you got that little chat bubble
I'm guessing you know that we all love
hey help you know one of those deals and
there's a premium version that gives you
priority level support for your
questions so if you still feel
uncomfortable filing taxes on your own
it's worth connecting with a tax Pro
we've got you covered there as well go
to ramseysolutions.com tax that's
ramseysolutions.com tax to learn more
about Ramsay smart tax or a Ramsay
trusted tax Pros like one of our
endorsed local provider that's
ramseysolutions.com
tax now I would be the person who just
does not trust my ability
details or quite frankly to be focused
long enough to do it right there and all
of a sudden I'm like score girl and I'm
looking at the latest news story or
something and so for years we've used a
Ramsay trusted tax Pro and endorse local
provider and and yes I got to pay for it
but the Peace of Mind
uh to not worry about it so yeah there
you go I hear that all right triple
eight eight two five five two two five
is the number let's go to Austin Texas
Teresa is there Teresa how can we help
hi hi thanks so much for taking my call
today
um I am getting ready to pay off my the
rest of my student loan and after that I
will just I will be debt-free except for
my mortgage which is 260 000
congratulations
thank you thank you
um I'm a sole parent of a 10 year old
and
um I really want to attack this um 260
000 mortgage but I'm feeling anxious or
like I need you know maybe an extra big
emergency fund bigger than the next
person kind of thing and I I just wanted
to get some guidance on that I am
driving a 12 year old car that has 200
000 miles my mechanic does think it will
make it three more years but I do have
that in my head that you know it might
not and I do have a very stable income
but I still am you know like a little
bit worried about going gung-ho in the
260 without a big enough emergency fund
yeah absolutely
um how much do you make a year
I'm self-employed and I have two sources
of income and it's around 216.
well done and how much if you've done if
you did a budget today how much do you
think your monthly expenses are out of
that
um I should have a better answer to this
question
um my son my mortgage is around 3 500
and my son goes to a private school
which is about 15
000 a year
um
and I am you know I have I have been
putting money in retirement even though
I know that you guys don't teach that
way I've been doing that and
um so and after my student loan is paid
then the rest of the way that frees up
an additional 500 a month for sure okay
so yep with your mortgage private school
all of that that's that's 4500 and then
cost of living everything else on top of
that so what I would do Terri says I
would do a very detailed budget if you
stay on the line Austin will pick up and
we'll get you
um a subscription to every dollar plus
because I do want you to know it's going
to help answer this question for you to
say hey what does every month look like
and you're going to list out all of your
expenses you're going to understand a
budget live on that for you know
probably two three months to really
understand this is a realistic budget
for me and then if I were in your shoes
um and hearing kind of your little risk
averse you're wanting a lot of safety
which I totally understand we say
anywhere from three to six months of
expenses but being self-employed uh
being a single mom having a child all of
that I would probably err on the side of
the six months just to give you extra
peace it's not going to hurt anything
and I would and I would put that and I
would even pause your investing to speed
that up to get that amount of cash in
the bank do you have any cash uh besides
what you're going to use to pay off your
student loans do you have anything else
yeah after the student loan is paid I'll
have 20 000 in my emergency oh my gosh
okay well done that's amazing so you've
already jump started that so I would
look at your expenses for your month
because the way I look at the emergency
fund people kind of do these numbers
differently depending on
um you know what they want I when
Winston and I looked at our emergency
fund number I said I want to know that
if we had no income coming in we would
not have to majorly change our life so
what is our day-to-day life what is a
what does a monthly budget look like for
our life and multiply that by six for
some people they say just look at my
needs you know I would cut everything
out and that's great too I'm like I just
like the extra extra cushion it just
feels good for me
um and so that if so run those numbers
how you want to say hey if something
were to happen and I wasn't making any
income you know how much do I want to
have saved and look that look at that
monthly budget that's going to help you
and I would multiply that by six start
saving towards that
um and put that in a high yield savings
count a money market account get have it
accessible though to be able to get to
it if you needed it and then after that
tree sessions with your car I mean I
would put you're making great money
you're going to be able to cash flow
some stuff but if you even want to you
know have another savings account that
you put a few thousand away for a car
and and make that a sinking fund where
you save up a little bit over time and
then you know in two years when you're
like okay I'm gonna sell this junky car
I've saved up this over time and I'm
going to apply this to the car you can
do that as well so
um but the the great thing here is your
income and you're gonna be able to do a
lot with that you're gonna be able to
invest and get that emergency fund
really quick and I yeah you're in a
really great position and and cheers to
you for being a single mom I owe single
parents out there
um we have a lot of respect for youth I
know there's a there's a lot riding on
your shoulders so well done yes oh thank
you so much yeah I had I had a little
um you know in 2020 my income had some
one of my contracts was not stable and
then I got the second one and the second
one is lower paying but it's very stable
and I can work as many hours as I want
the part of me is like you don't have to
be as risk averse as you are but I still
you know I am feeling you know really
cautious yeah and I get that that's fine
it's okay that's not gonna that's not
gonna hurt you uh you know in any way
and I gotta say this Beyond being a
single mom you're a solopreneur and I
mean you you got two businesses I mean
you're our Superwoman you really are and
a credit to you there's no stopping you
the reason I'm putting that out is it's
tough enough being a single mom but then
you're running your businesses you're
crushing it as Rachel said you've done a
wonderful job so I hope you're
encouraged uh that you're that it's okay
to be cautious but now be bold because
you've got a good strategy and listen
you're going to get where you want to
get there's no stopping you you got me
thank you thank you I really appreciate
the the kind words thank you so much you
bet I mean you're absolutely amazing you
know Rachel there's something about that
Mama Bear
these deadbeat dads uh spineless gutless
I know they're in pain but they're still
spineless and gutless because she's in
pain and she shows up takes care of the
babies starts one business somewhere
along the line another one has gotten
herself in good financial position and
it just needs to be called out that it
is hard to stop a mama bear I know I
love it she's killing it absolutely
incredible absolutely incredible really
awesome thank you so much Teresa for the
call and for sharing a little bit of
your story you're a rock star and uh you
know what let's come around these single
moms shall we if there's one in your
community let's come around them
whatever that looks like let's help them
out they deserve it uh great hour Rachel
Cruz thank you so much for hanging out
as always want to thank James Childs and
the illustrious crew behind the glass
that keep us on the air and you America
for listening thank you this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsey Show it's where we help you win
with your money and we'll look at your
work component your relationship
component around the all-important
element of money so that you can win and
win big and live that life you desire to
live triple eight eight two five five
two two five is the phone number eight
eight two five five two two five I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague the
incomparable the fabulous
Rachel Cruz and uh we're here for you
this hour she'll take your money
questions I might pipe in I might not
you never know and if you've got any of
those work questions that relate to
making more money getting out of a tough
environment uh but not losing that
income I'm here to help in those
specific questions as well let's go to
Houston Texas where Layla joins us Layla
how can we help
hi thank you guys for both taking my
call I appreciate it sure
um we went to Missouri my husband and I
are getting closer time and age and uh
we're just looking for a place to get we
love Houston but City Life we don't want
to you know we need a little getaway
from City Life and retirement age
um so long story short I went to
Missouri found a piece of property fell
in love with it
um
and we would just want to know if it's a
good idea to buy it or not my son's in
love with it he wants to move out of
Texas
and he wants to work in Missouri
um and he says he would love to live
there and raise a family on that piece
of property so the end goal is just
going to be him raising his family but
we're going to enjoy it once we're we're
here okay and you're calling us to get
our opinion on this I'm curious what are
you nervous about what are you unsure
about what's the piece of information we
don't have as to why you wouldn't buy it
well I just want to make sure like I'm
we're financially okay right now what
does that mean and I just want to make
sure so
um the uh we have
we have uh our some Investments
um and we have how much are in those we
can pay for the property okay so
Investments are
about eight hundred eight hundred
thousand and are those in retirement or
just in the market when you say
Investments is it mutual funds uh 401K
Roth IRA are just strictly mutual funds
mutual funds rothai and I think a sec
okay yeah my husband has a set yep okay
great and um
and so we have that going and then a a
liquid or in the bank we have uh one 1.6
so great job Layla
well no thank you thank you hard work
hard work yeah well done well done how
much is the land
the land as well they want 1. 1.18
on the land but we're gonna have to do
some work to the house there's a house
on it
yeah but it's a little house it needs a
little work it's a little Farmhouse have
you run comps on this how or how or how
many acres too
it's a 290 something 293 I think 293 293
Acres
I was confused okay and and before
Rachel breaks the money down I just
really curious I want to make sure I
heard you right you and your husband
want to move to Missouri and live on
this and then eventually your son comes
and raises his family on it is that what
I heard
um yes so my my husband and I we don't
want to move out of you so we're going
to keep our home here in Houston oh okay
Missouri is going to be you know to get
away from Houston whenever we want to
get away from you soon live there maybe
a few months in retirement gosh you know
and then just always come back to you so
we don't want to give up the home here
gotcha okay all right
um okay and so the house needs some
Renovations you know how much that will
cost
um you know what he's a paint uh
bathrooms rip out the carpet maybe about
45 50 on the max side I'm sitting on the
max side okay okay
um
all right and then you're and then your
son
may come on the property as well right
and build his own thing but you guys
would just
kind of gift to that are you expecting
him to buy a a partial
um
within that lot
no we're my son's 17 he's going to be
off to college but actually oh okay gosh
in my head yeah I'm sorry I got you I'm
sorry that's my thought I didn't tell
you that far but he is uh after college
he fell in love with it he doesn't he
wants to move someplace colder he
doesn't like the heat in Houston so in
love with this property he loves it
um he's always told us this is not a
spontaneous thing that you know that he
always wanted a piece of I'm sure he
does so you can drive this Campground
yeah yeah no I think that's great okay
but you guys would buy this property not
for the 17 year old that could meet
sweet little Anna here in three years
and move out and move up to Chicago with
her family or something like yeah
regardless of whether the 17 year old
likes this property you guys like this
property
my husband is in love with this part
okay and yeah she's in love with it
um
I mean
you you guys are in an incredible
financial situation I mean your your
everyday millionaires is your house in
Houston paid off
yes okay so yeah you got and how much
longer are you guys gonna work
um
he's probably maybe another seven eight
years yeah and what's your house in
Houston worth right now if you sold it
[Music]
um
maybe about four okay yeah so you've got
the cash to pay for this land plus the
renovations on the small home
um yes we do but you know I'm just
thinking about you know when we get
older medical expenses and then if we
have to move into a you know retirement
home is it really worth can we just keep
the cash and just fund our own old age
or should we buy this piece of property
which is a dream property for us
so you're asking not how to buy the
property but if you should buy it or not
yes well that would be wise knowing that
you know we're going to be elderly and
probably the expenses that come with I
mean I think it's something to consider
but honestly we talk about you live like
no one else so later you get to live and
give like no one else so Layla I mean
honestly realistically in 10 years if
you guys hate it and want out it's only
going to go up in value and sell it and
go do your own thing you're not tied to
it forever if you pay cash and and you
guys need more money than you've
invested and you're gonna make that
money back and then some so I don't
think it's risky at all not to mention I
think you told us you already got 800
000 in the bank uh in other Investments
so you got your home in Houston that's
cash uh that's worth almost a half a
million maybe in several you know in 10
years so I just think you're sitting
pretty and this is not risky at all
Rachel and you can always flip this
property if you get if you had to have
it yeah there's no risk that you're
taking on here yeah and you guys are
still gonna be working
um funding retirement that 800 will keep
going up and uh I like it I like the
move I think it's great and again it
goes back to a it's a Layla and you're
and and the husband conversation I think
at that point from the money side
there's no big red flags
um but but I want to make sure you want
to do this too I know he loves the
property is this what you want to do
with with your money
you know you guys are speaking to my
heart yes I want to but I have a problem
partying with the money I'm a little bit
insecure with that and he's he's you
know but I I you guys are giving me
confidence and saying no you're going to
be yeah I think you're fine it's a lot
of money I mean you're writing a woman
it's a one million dollar check so
nothing to sneeze out here so I get that
I would want to throw up a little bit
too when you're like okay here it goes I
think you and the hubs uh a romantic
dinner talk it through maybe a little
Rod Stewart Forever Young maybe in the
background you know this is like this
fun young thing that's gonna keep you
guys young as you get older and it's a
big adventure that you could afford I I
say do it I love it
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
Shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed Perfect Fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
thank you
you are listening to the Ramsey Show I'm
Ken Coleman I'm joined by my colleague
Rachel Cruz and we're here for you this
hour taking your money questions also
taking your work questions and
relationship questions around these
issues
of money triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five
two two five it's time for our question
of the day and it's brought to you by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
when you need to make repairs schedule
routine maintenance or find local help
for Home Improvement projects
neighborly is your source for Reliable
home service providers in your area go
to neighborly.com to start your search
and today's question comes from
I see Al
on Smart money happy hour I said Al one
time and it was AI is this a is this a
joke are y'all playing a joke on me I
mean it says l
I don't know I feel like I've missed the
entire thing I said I feel like I just
tell the story after the question tell
us okay
okay I'm gonna say ow and Silicon Valley
okay no this is y'all Silicon Valley
they're pulling stuff they're messing
with me it says I'm 23 in a recent
college graduates I'm currently working
making 50k a year graduate without debt
currently have 20 in my savings 20 000
in my savings my monthly rent is 700 my
car is paid for my question is how
should I be investing my money at this
stage of my life
um man well Al AI if you're even real uh
this is this is great I mean I would I
would at this point you probably hit
that 20 000 I would say is a fully
funded emergency fund for you so I would
take your income and start investing 15
of it
into retirement and if your employer
offers a 401k I would go up to the match
uh open up a Roth IRA fund that and
yeah fun fifteen percent fifteen percent
of your income there okay so George and
I were on a smart money Happy Hour
podcast and we have some notes for all
the stuff we do and I'm just kind of
reading it I'm like yeah
uh and I said and it was about
counterfeits I think it's actually out I
think it's the episode that's out today
and it talks about how there are
companies now that will it'll go through
a system to make sure that it's
authentic right that the item is that
it's on a counterfeit item and it said
and it has an an owl helps out with this
so I say Alex well everyone loses it
right and they're like you're a
six-year-old woman Rachel right it's AI
but it looks like ow well because in
your defense in your defense it wasn't
like the old school Capital where you
got a straight line and two crosses
there so but it was just the one line
and you see Al the uppercase i and the
lowercase L look very similar and
there's no periods in between those so
anyways
and I just had like like PTSD right
there looking out in Silicon Valley
y'all did that to me yeah that was a
real question but we couldn't resist the
opportunity to troll you with the fake
names I learned my lesson yeah wiser
beyond my years you figured it out Joke
is on them there you go
watch out for Al it's gonna take all of
our jobs like they have Al in the back
all right let's get going here to the
phones hey we're having fun I hope you
are let's go to Mark in Orlando Florida
uh let's see here he is Mark how can we
help
good afternoon I was calling just in
regards to looking over the numbers my
wife and I I have in front of us here
and wondering if there's any way out
except bankruptcy oh no what's going on
we have
um about 200 and
135 000 in debt
about 214 000 of that I'm sorry about
180 000 of that is in judgments and in
um
you know loans that weren't paid off and
a judgment from us from my company
we have about fifty thousand dollars in
car loans and I had to close the company
and we're looking at a new salary with a
new company I just started with at only
about 55 000 a year
wow what what happened with the with the
old company with the judgments and
everything
we had taken out a few loans uh to try
to keep things going over the last year
and a half
and those loans kept deducting payments
weekly
and then we had uh material that was
back ordered and we weren't able to come
up with the money after those oh I'm so
sorry Mark we could continue to be
deducted so everything just kind of
snowball apart quickly yeah
oh I'm so sorry
um okay do you guys
um
is your house how much do you guys owe
in your house
well that's not yeah that's not even
including that we literally just moved
into the house last April we bought that
wheel about 300 on that 300 okay
any other Consumer Debt besides the car
loans
uh no we don't have any credit cards we
don't have any student loans or anything
we don't own anything so we just own the
vehicles which is about a truck which is
thirty four thousand we still owe on and
15 000 on my wife's car how much are
those cars worth
probably a lot less than that what were
you making or what were you paying
yourself when you when you're working
for yourself what were you paying
yourself
um
it depended on the time of season I
owned an air conditioning business right
so it was seasonal and it was there was
never a consistent way to right figure
out what was it but were you making more
than 55 000 at any point
oh yeah yeah we were bringing home 90
000 the last two years in a row yeah the
reason I bring this up is
um I want to know what your income
potential is because as you start to
Wade through this the max amount of
income possible for both of you is what
we're going to need to try to figure out
and line that up so it allows us to dig
out of this or at least consider what
would it take to dig out of this without
filing bankruptcy is your why
it all mark
um she was doing you know stay-at-home
mother but she picked up babysitting uh
now so
making a little bit of cash but not much
how old are your kids about a thousand
dollars a month my son is five my
daughter is about to be a year oh wow
yeah
you are in the thick of it for sure
um
okay well here's here's looking at
everything I would eliminate Mark as
much as possible like in as as fast as
possible just to get some breathing room
so honestly even though the car is 34
maybe you can sell it for 20 and you'd
you know you would take a fourteen
thousand dollar loan for the difference
I would do something
just to feel like I have a level of
control over what's going on because I
know you feel like you're spinning out
of control with all of this
um and so getting rid of the cars taking
a small loan uh for the difference where
you guys are and then I would be looking
at your 180
as
as almost like a student loan in my head
because like we get numbers like this on
the show of
so much debt usually it's in the form of
student loans when we see high
six-figure debt but I'm telling you Mark
I re I don't think you're at the brink
of bankruptcy
um but I do want to make sure that your
priorities and what you guys are doing
with this new income because it is
significantly less less that it's going
to the right things at the right time
while you continue
to maybe even look for a second job and
do what you can to up that because food
shelter utilities and transportation is
our goal and I know the house you guys
just moved in in April but I want you to
run a budget Mark and see if it is if it
is over your mortgage plan has over 25
of your take-home pay I would look at
selling and downsizing
um I would do some drastic things uh in
order to be able to attack this 180 uh
really really well and again that's
going to mean possibly downsizing home
selling cars
and even taking on another job or two
just so you can get your head above
water because you're scared Mark you
have a baby and a little one at home and
your wife is your sweet wife is yeah
doing babysitting to bring in some extra
cash and so
um there has to be some dressing I don't
think you guys are at the point of
bankruptcy I know it feels hopeless but
if you hold the line Mark Austin's gonna
pick up and we're going to give you
Financial Peace University and you and
your wife walk through this and say you
have a road ahead of you Mark it's not
going to be easy you have you have years
ahead of you of climbing out of this but
I really
we avoid bankruptcy at all costs and I
just do not think you're bankrupt you
feel hopeless but you're not bankrupt
yeah I agree Mark you're gonna have to
work and work and work and then when you
think you can't work anymore keep
working you have a lot of skill set and
you should be making way more you have
to make more and it will help and
Rachel's right hang on the line though
we're going to get you some help uh you
guys can do this you just need a
community and you need some steps and
we've got it for you hang on this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague
Rachel Cruz this hour the number to jump
in for your questions is triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five now Rachel you're big on The Talk
uh in the gram I mean you're the gram
more the gram Than The Talk The Talk is
there it's there uh yeah you and I don't
actually do it
because I don't I'm not a big fan of
this talk me either scares me a little
bit I get it but uh you are the social
media and I do love you're really good I
love the gram though the grandma you're
really great on the gram uh if you don't
know what we're talking about we're
seeing the Instagram uh it's kind of
like the Google you know you got to
check all these things out and some of
these amazing Trends now
are things like bare minimum Monday this
was made famous by a tick talker who
said she needs uh half of the day Monday
to just get herself ready to work again
yeah
it takes her sometimes back so she calls
it bare minimum Monday she tries to do
the least amount of possible at work on
Monday and then of course you've heard
of The Quiet quitting phrase which is
I'm only gonna do the bare minimum so I
don't get fired and this is all about
just not wanting to work like it's it's
it's people who aren't fulfilled instead
of getting mad at these people Rachel I
see is they don't have a reason for
going in yeah they don't see something
that they uh enjoy it's not meaningful
to them and that's why we created a
really popular tool here called the get
clear career assessment if you would
like to actually enjoy your Mondays and
not drink your face off on Friday
afternoon because you're so miserable at
the work uh at the office or or in your
remote job you just want to enjoy your
work and make money this is the tool for
you it'll help you get a very clear
report on how uniquely you are put
together what you do best what you love
to do and then what motivates you and
this is very helpful it's a
self-awareness tool gives you a purpose
statement that kind of points you
towards a real professional opportunity
and you know what you're looking for and
thus you can find it it's called The get
clear career assessment it's about an
18-minute assessment and uh it's really
going to give you Clarity and confidence
go to ramseysolutions.com get clear
ramseysolutions.com
and I'll say it's amazing thank you very
much it is amazing
um let's get now to the phones Billings
Montana do you watch do you watch
Yellowstone you know we you haven't
watched it I can I'm gonna say I didn't
get fully immersed but everyone loves it
so all right I see Montana and I gotta
talk about it yes and I want to know
Linda do you live on like a ranch
and are you like a cowgirl do you make
fun of that show because it's not real I
mean what's the story Linda
you know what I haven't had my TV on for
45 years
whoa wait a minute but I did yeah but uh
I love Montana I don't live on a ranch
but I love it and um I I ran into Kevin
Costner and when I did uh he was so nice
and he was so humble and I got his
autograph yes
and it's amazing you it's amazing you
even knew who he was I assume you've
gone to the movies just haven't turned
the TV on in 45 years well it was one of
these things where I just bought my
little you know sandwich and I looked
and I'm like I know that face and then
it was oh
oh my
God your body of work and his little kid
just looked at me that's an idiot
that's great Linda great celebrity story
I'm so glad to know that he was
everything we hoped he would be yes I'm
so glad to know that he was nice oh it's
nice it was humble so I'm calling to see
should I sell this signature on eBay
yes make some extra cash that's
hilarious Linda you're a great spirit oh
well this is so fun to talk to you Linda
how can we help you today
well my dear 97 Year young friend just
went to be with the Lord and she gave me
twenty thousand dollars and I am just
shocked oh my god wow yeah we met doing
prison ministry together and that's when
code was going around and nobody would
take her to her doctor's appointments
you know and kind of hung in there and
did all but anyway it's just it was a
joy so I don't want to do something
stupid and um I feel like the Lord's
saying sit on it for a year and so what
should I do with it local bank uh a CD
um I yeah yeah no that's so great well
um a great place to park money short
term would we would always recommend a
money market account or even a high
yield savings account
um those are going to be your two Best
Bets and you can do those
um you know some local established banks
have that option but also a lot of
online banks that aren't brick and
mortar that may make you I don't know
how you feel about that uh they're
perfectly safe but sometimes you can get
a better rate of return on an online
bank at times so like a bank like Ally I
would look into that's where my husband
and I have our child savings account
through uh but that or a money market I
think is is a great option for now and
and
um not that I don't want I want you to
be obedient to what you feel like the
Lord is saying for you to doing that
with that money for sure but do for you
Linda in your financial situation where
are you at do you have debt do you have
retirement
yeah I live in a 1961 mobile home I have
a used car with 371 000 miles on it a
Toyota
um I just picked up a side hustle job at
a box store and um I was a part-time
teacher I'm also an actress
um and I just get a little check of
about 700 a month and then it goes up
thirteen dollars you know uh every year
and
um but on the side hustle job get paid
you know every two weeks faithfully and
it's about 600. my debt is about 17
119.55 but I just you know and I know
from taking the classes or they should
pay all the debt off but I I just don't
know
um Big Ticket items I need termite and
my the dryer went out so I'm hanging the
clothes up and a used car eventually and
a new bed so that's kind of you know
after all the debts paid off I I did
have the emergency fund and then during
the whole covered stuff and then I
retired at 58 I'm 63 now I kind of went
through you know that so there's a
little in the bank so I'm kind of you
know starting over but okay I spent a
lot on missions trips
um and giving to other people and
helping them out and stuff yeah and I'm
very content you know with where I live
sure I just you know I told her
daughters when I just got blown away by
this I feel like she would want it you
know for the Lord
um she would sin when I traveled the
world a lot in my 30s and 40s she would
uh give me little missionary tracks from
in different languages African and
Germany all over and I just feel like
she would want it you know to go for
that but when I drove her by my mobile
home was it's a wooden Clinton there and
she said I think it's time for a new
house oh but um
uh Linda Linda you're so sweet I could
talk to you literally and Rachel and I
could talk to you for hours you're a
delight but I'm going to tell you
something we're gonna you know what
we're gonna tell you this is a gift that
your friend gave you and you don't need
to attach all kinds of things to it
she's in heaven and and and this is a
gift and I think you wanted to take care
of you if you were my mom uh or my
friend I'd say pay this debt off and and
get that debt out of your life at this
age you don't need to be carrying that
debt you've got your side hustles you
got ways of bringing in income but that
debt needs to be gone and then you can
take care of the bed and what a blessing
that it's basically almost to the exact
dollar amount I mean you may have 2500
left but but that's a that's an amazing
thing because something is true that
releases I think not just financially
but emotionally spiritually
physiology like when you don't owe
anyone anything when scripture says the
borrower is slave to the lender there is
wisdom in that there is wisdom that you
don't have the ability to be completely
free Linda that when you make an income
and you and you want to be able to be
even more generous than you are
you have to be making these payments to
this debt you know so when you don't owe
anyone anything there is a freedom and a
beautiful Legacy a beautiful Legacy uh
that you can leave that your friend had
left you and I think that that is a that
is a a wise way to use this to carry her
on her Legacy on through your story so
you are wonderful Linda I'm so glad that
you called in today and Linda Rachel's
right I think she's preaching I think
you need to hear the message the sermon
because here's the deal you pay that
debt off it's frees you up to go on more
missions trips to give to missions you
need that out of your life so that you
can give more of who you are and you are
fantastic Linda thank you so much for
calling what a gift use it
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken Coleman I'm
joined in Studio by Rachel Cruz this
hour triple eight eight two five five
two two five is the number our scripture
of the day comes from Proverbs 13 20.
whoever walks with the wise becomes wise
but the companion of fools will suffer
harm and our quote of the day Adam
Sandler fantastic Adam Sandler quote I
mean I don't think I've ever had a
sailor quote this is great it's hard to
shower with the Eagles when you're
surrounded by the turkeys that's my best
out of Sailor that's all I got that's
back at the guys I don't know if that's
any good or not that's really good no
it's good
I tried uh and you know what he's right
um he's right hard to soar when you're
around the church okay
but we're all
but we're all turkeys to a degree are we
yeah you're right you know what we are
look at me trying to yeah
not all the time it's really there's a
humility part too that we all have a
level of turkey in us so and you know
what turkeys are also why are we banging
on turkeys turkeys are tasty they taste
great you know they help us take naps
they have the they're fun to draw when
you're a kid
you get the whole nine yards folks I
need to probably get my medication I'm
I'm doing Adam Sandler voices turkey
sounds what is happening Seattle
Washington is where we go next we're
having fun Micah is there Micah how can
we help
hey um how are you guys doing uh we're
having fun I just tried to impersonate
Adam Sandler I mean if we're at a new
level Micah so good luck yeah I don't
know what the advice is gonna be I'm not
sure what's going to happen but we're
here to help that's right what's up
great
yes so I want to give you guys a little
context here so I'm 17 years old and I'm
doing running start this year so I'll
only have to do like around three and a
half years of college to complete a
bachelor's degree and basically I I'm
trying to decide between going to work
at Starbucks and doing their online ASU
program where they would pay for my
college 100 free and like working there
over the years I would probably make
around like 50 to 60 000 in total
um but as a Christian though
um I want to go to this private
Christian University near my home and I
would probably be able to pay it all off
without loans and stuff so my question
kind of is should I be sort of miserable
working at Starbucks and not have as
many friends for the years in college
but have a bunch of money to start out
with or should I enjoy my College
college experience but not really have
much money to start out with well uh you
know
if you if you're my son asking me this
question I'm gonna go hey the fact that
you can cash flow college and not go
into debt are you getting the money
Micah for a private Christian University
that's that has to be expensive
yes so um it's about so I have over 50
of the scholarships
um sorry for the tuition so it's 16 500
per year about
um so it would be like a total of around
fifty seven thousand dollars but
basically I've I've been working a
little bit so I have around like seven
thousand dollars right now and also my
parents are going to be able to help
with that do it as well it's a
no-brainer because you really want to do
it and you're not going into debt
um if that were not the case I'd say
yeah go bust it at Starbucks and get
your education paid for but you really
want to do this so I see no reason why
you wouldn't
okay yeah that's yeah that's definitely
what I'm wanting to do definitely well
you didn't need our permission but I
appreciate the question because you're
you're wanting to know it's good to be
yeah you want to know if this is a sound
decision and here's here's what you were
worried about if I do this Ken Rachel
I'm gonna come out and I'm not gonna
have much money but who cares you're not
in debt and now you can go work and as a
young guy you're not going to need a
bunch of money you'll be fine
that's true that's a good point all
right so go do it go enjoy it and if you
change your mind here's the thing that I
that I want to just say this is a little
soapbox thing we live in a day and age
that if we go to college because culture
has told us Rachel that college is the
best way to success that if we go to
college and we get in there and we
realize this isn't for me or we go one
route with a major and then we realize I
don't really want to do this we feel
ashamed to just make a change yeah and I
just want to say be free
it's your life that's right that's right
here's what anybody says make the change
yes and by being wise in the decision
which he is I'm like you're just you're
weighing options you're actually looking
at options versus saying like this is
the only thing I can do
um and so it is true the college
conversation is getting more interesting
I feel like by the by the day because we
are getting so many calls we did a
millionaire theme hour last week with
Dave and over half the callers never had
a college degree you know so it's uh
asked me if I have a college degree
do you have a college degree nope I
thought you did nope nope went to
Virginia and worked politics College
Dropout went to work campaign you didn't
graduate from like did not graduate
because I because I tasted battle and
then I went back to the classroom and
was bored out of my mind and I left
and I got about a semester and a half
left and I'm never gonna do it so there
you go a semester and a half couldn't
care less could care less yeah let's go
to Sean next in Cleveland Ohio here's
all the non-college grads that aren't
losers
Sean how can we help
hi how you doing we're having fun what's
going on
uh just finished Financial Peace
University with my wife and congrats
every thank you every uh three months
that we've been doing that we've been
over budget and my wife loves Rachel and
the way that she explains things but she
doesn't seem to be following him as much
as I I'd like to
um just wondering how to get we have our
budget community meeting tonight and I
want to make sure we're set up to not go
over this coming month and try to work
that in a way that she understands
instead of
you know I mean what what ends up being
the problem Sean what's the what's the
over like how much are you guys over
and are you oh a couple couple Grand a
couple grams yeah yeah it's uh are we
just ignoring what we're making now and
we're we're just she she had that
student loan pause and I want to attack
that
um as well as a mortgage and I guess the
student loan thing I want to wait like
set aside x amount of dollars until they
resume it so we can just write a check
and be done
all right I think she's thinking oh
it'll be fine we have money saved and I
just we can't get on that right well why
are you two thousand dollars over budget
because
our daughters in cheer and competitions
that come up there's uh all these
expenses that go into that there's uh
that's a racket that's true
yeah wonderful wagons coming to play and
oh yeah you gotta yeah you got it I'm
like it's not even summer yet so once
the money starts being spent in summer
it's going to be a lot more but
luckily we have saving but I don't want
to keep spending things oh yeah yeah
you got to get even I don't want you
dipping into your savings to fund
cheerleading and all that so
um tell your wife love her too but we
have to focus on the we have to we have
to do math and
this isn't like a shameful
um statement but it's just true it's
fifth grade math we our income is this
our expenses are this and including
giving and saving in that it needs to
equal zero so we have to make choices
sometimes hard choices within that
income so if our choices we want to do
competition cheer for the daughter then
other parts of our life are going to
have to shrink in order to do that we'll
make some money for it or yeah maybe we
make some extra money
um but there there has to be you you you
guys can't continue to be in the red
because your savings only is going to
last you so long so that's not it's not
a wise plan so your lifestyles
both of you as a family are above what
you make which is normal and America
that's how people live but we're not
talking about normal we're being weird
here and so
um there's going to have to be some some
hard yeah some hard decisions that you
guys as a family and this isn't Sean you
pointing at her and saying well you're
doing this and you don't know you need
to say to what what Sean is thinking and
Sean says Sean is feeling I'm kind of
getting frustrated I want to be on the
same page I'm you know you got to point
it back to you don't point the finger
yeah but tell her I love her love her
love her butt but we really need to
touch it I think we need to cheer give
me an S give me an I give me a D give me
an e give me an H give me a u give me an
S give me a t give me an L give me an e
what does that spell side hustle go pay
for the cheerleading mama if you want it
in the budget whoa watch out Rachel Cruz
greatest shower thank you James Charles
and the team this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]